welcome everyone on this
topic of the docker commands over here
in this topic we are going to talk about
what exactly
is the various docker commands which we
can use to
interact with the docker docker images
docker containers and some core
components of
docker is what we are going to talk
about in this particular topic here
now let's begin with what exactly is in
docker because we
are trying to explore that what are the
different docker commands we can
eventually
run to interact with the docker because
uh you have the command line interface
which is available there using which you
can run
some couple of docker commands and
internally you know you will be able to
have some
particular processing which is done at
the docker end
now docker is in configuration
management tool it's being used as a
configuration management tool
just like the other configuration
management tools uh in the industry in
the market
now it's pretty much used by the
developers to make sure that they
wrap or they package an application with
all its dependency
now normally in a virtual machine what
we do is that we host or we install the
dependencies separately
and then on top of that we host our web
applications or whatever the application
we have we
host it on that particular framework or
platform
but here in this scenario we are talking
about like how we can wrap
an application all together with its
dependencies
all the dependencies are getting wrapped
are getting uh
packaged up into a single entity and
you know that's what we call it as a
docker container so docker is in
configuration management tool and the
containerization tool which is there
which helps us to wrap or package both
the dependencies and the source code
within a single unit called docker
container and this is the docker
container which the developers use to do
the deployment
across multiple environments so um
as part of the process when you are
working on the
hosting of your application onto your
docker
so ultimately you are looking forward
for an entity called docker container
so if you see if you go through the
diagram over here so in this one
this is in kind of a basic way uh
architecture that how the docker
is being architect and is getting
deployed
so initially you have an infrastructure
like a physical infrastructure is there
you have the uh particular cores memory
infrastructure all those things are
available there now on top of this
infrastructure you are hosting up a host
operating system
this host operating system is
responsible for taking up all the
requests
and interacting uh providing a
particular interface between the
uh particular docker and the
infrastructure the core hardware
so it acts like a medium over here so
after the host on
operating system on top of that you are
going to install the docker engine
docker software
it's just like you got a virtual machine
on linux and on top of that you are
installing the docker software
once the docker engine is installed then
docker engine will take care of
management of the docker containers
you don't really have to uh do a lot of
work docker engine is going to take all
the internal work
uh the communication between the
operating system and the
infrastructure so that needs to be done
by the docker engine so docker engine
make sure that the current different
container gets uh
up and running and you can see that in
this scenario in this diagram
we have container one container two and
container three
and all these containers are actually
having its own
applications and the dependencies bind
it up together
so that's the reason why we are saying
that with the docker we are getting a
complete package
end-to-end package is being given to us
in which we have both the
uh particular source code and the
binaries and the executables embedded
inside that
so it's a complete package which is
getting created
in the form of docker container and the
developer is responsible for preparing
this docker container
so that these containers can be deployed
on the docker host
and you can get your application up and
running
so this is what we have docker into our
particular and the architecture of the
docker here
now let's see that what are the
different commands we have for the
docker here
now the very first one is that what are
the different images
related to commands which is available
there the very first one
is the command which we typically use to
prepare a custom docker image
now i can easily go to the docker hub
and i can pull down
a docker image which is available there
but let's assume that you are working on
application source code
so uh you want to prepare a docker
container for that
now that docker container you will not
be able to have it on the docker hub
you have to prepare on your own right
so in order to prepare your own docker
image all you have to do is that you
have to run docker build command
now in this case we have to prepare a
docker file
which will act like a docker a kind of a
docker build script
just like in case of maven we have power
xml file and in case of and we have
built.xml file
so here we have the dockerfile which is
available there and this dockerfile make
sure that whatever
the steps are mentioned in this docker
file in the build script
it's going to perform a series of steps
and the build will be done
so docker build is the command hyphen t
is the tag that what exactly name
uh you know whatever the image you are
building
so what exactly tag name you're trying
to provide over here so here we are
using a tag name called my image
and then after the column we are
providing that what version we want to
go here
1.0 2.0 5.0 so whatever the version you
feel that you want to
uh you know refer you can do that now
this is the exact way
that how in the actual world the docker
images are getting built up by the
respective vendors let's say that
jenkins is one l jenkins wants to
prepare a docker image
so they will be preparing the docker
file in the same manner and prepare
these docker images and publish it to
the
docker hub so all the docker images are
built up the custom docker images are
built up with the help of
docker files so docker build is the
command which will process the docker
file and give you a
particular docker image in the end
now how to list down all the docker
images so docker list
ls is something which is there so this
will eventually help you to list down
all the docker images which is
listed on or which is available into
your system so that will be
listed out over there for you if you
feel that you want to remove
a particular image in that case you can
go for docker image
rm command and uh whatever the image you
want to remove you can give the
respective
image name and the tag name there so
docker image rm command is there using
which you can actually see that how
the image can be deleted from the host
over here in this one
right so whatever the ways whatever the
you know
mechanism is there so we are making sure
that how
the image can be built up and how we can
go for the
uh built up and a particular image can
be deployed over here in this case so
in order to delete it in docker image so
you can go for docker
image rm command to remove a docker
image completely from the docker host
so these are some couple of commands
which is available there using which you
can actually interact or manage the
docker image
because in order to prepare in order to
run a docker container
we require a source and that source we
are going to get it from the
docker image so now we are going to see
that how we can execute these commands
though first of all what we need to do
is that we need to see that how docker
build works
for that we require a docker file so i
am going to have a simple docker file
over here
in which we are going to have a basic uh
docker image selected as an ubuntu
after that we are going to go for the
one attribute where we are going to do
the installation of a specific
package like let's say git and
accordingly you can whatever software
you want to prepare you want to set up
you can do that and put up the commands
over here in this
docker file so i'm going to save this
file and after that what i need to do is
that i need to run like
docker images to find out that how many
images are there there is no images
present so
i'm going to build a docker image over
here with the name of
simplylan or whatever the name you want
to give you can
uh give it over here in this case it's
not any kind of restricted word
so you can give the actual docker image
name also that what for what purpose you
are preparing this image
and with that what will happen that it
will take up the
values whatever attributes you have put
up into the docker file
so that will be processed and that will
be picked up and once that uh
docker file has been processed has been
uh you know prepared
you will be able to see that yes a final
product or a final docker image
is finalized and prepared over here in
this one so we just have to wait for the
whole process to complete
and once my docker image is prepared i
will be able to have
a particular setup done or achieved over
here so that's what we require
over here in this one to be performed
now once the installation is done so you
will be able to see like the
final docker image is being prepared
over here so it says successfully built
which means that
the docker image is prepared now if you
run like docker images you will be able
to find out that this image
is available over here in this one now
you are seeing like two images
because one is like the basic image
which is being pulled down
because we are using a docker file to do
that to process that one there now in
case you want to remove it so all you
need to do is that you need to run like
docker
image rm and simply learn
so if you do that what will happen that
your docker image which is related to
simply learn
will be wiped off from your system and
in case you want to do
like removal of the uber to also so that
also you can do
over here with the help of docker
images and that will be
removed from your system so your docker
images will be removed from your system
using the uh particular command called
docker
um image and then rm command to remove
the docker image from your
system from your host here so that's how
you
deal with the different docker images uh
commands over here in this one
now let's go back to the document now
the next section over here is the docker
container
commands over here so all the commands
related to docker containers
is what we are going to talk about over
here now the very first one
is the uh particular container so in
order to create a container so you can
run the command called docker create and
the image
because for a container you require a
docker image that's a pre-request so
once the docker image is prepared you
can just simply run docker create
command
and that will help you to create a
container onto your system
now if you want to run a particular
you want to create a container and you
want to run it also at the same time
so in that situation you can go for a
docker run command
the main difference between the docker
create and docker run command is that
the docker run command
is going to run a container and
it's going to give you a response from
the command but
the docker create command is going to
create only the container so once the
container is up and running so that's
only being done by the docker create
command
but the docker run command is going to
actually do the uh
preparation of the container also and at
the same time you are being given as in
particular
response also like you know what a
command you want to run so that response
also
you will be able to get here and if you
feel that you want to rename an existing
container so for that you can go for the
docker rename command so existing
container you can rename it with the new
container
and that's how the particular rename of
an existing container will be done
with on to the docker host here so
docker rename is the command using which
you can rename an existing container and
you can get a new container over here in
this case
so these are some of the options some of
the ways that how you can interact with
the containers
how you can manage them onto your docker
host over here so you can run it
you can create it and you can rename the
containers also
so now what we're going to do is that
we're going to see that how we can
work on this particular container
commands here so first of all i'm going
to
quickly pull down jenkins image so that
i can create a container out of that
so it's in kind of a 600 around me
docker image which is available there
now you can also have a custom docker
image prepared using the dockerfile or
you can have a ready-made docker image
pull down from the docker hub also so
this is going to pull the latest version
of the jenkins
from the docker hub so that we will be
able to proceed further on that and we
will be able to continue with the
hosting so we will be converting or
running this uh specific docker images
in the form of docker containers so that
we will be able to have uh instance of
docker container over here running in
this one so that's what we are trying to
do here so we just wait for this pull
activity to complete because it's an uh
heavy docker image so it may take some
time to download and once it's download
you will be able to see
that docker images is
showing a specific docker image of
jenkins here
now you're going to create a container
out of that so you're going to run a
command called docker
create and jenkins over here
so that will help us to do uh the
creation of a docker container
and once that is done so you will be
able to see like using docker ps command
that if any container is up and running
and if you go for docker psyphony
you will be able to see that yes a
particular docker container is in
created mode now this is not in running
mode because you see that when i ran the
docker ps command it was not showing it
in the running mode because
i just created a docker container here
and the created status also
shows that yes the docker container is
created but it did not run over here
so if you want to run it so definitely
you can say like docker
start and uh
you can give the container name and that
will help me to
start my container over here but of
course you if you feel that you want to
directly
create a container and you know you
don't want to create the container only
you want to start it also
so in that case you can go for the
docker run command so docker run
command is something which can be used
instead of
uh doing the execution so you can say
like docker
run jenkins and what it will do it will
definitely help you to get the
container created onto of the jenkins
over here
in this case it's not like only creating
a container but in fact it's
actually starting the container also so
you can see that it started over here
into your screen itself that whole
jenkins gets initialized over here in
this one so this is the way that how
you can initialize or you can create a
container
now i can just do a control c over here
because it says that and jenkins is up
and running
so you can start using this one
according to your requirement over here
right so i'm just doing ctrl c so that
it can be stopped over there
right now so this is the way that how
uh typically we can create the
containers now we got like two
containers over here
and one is up and running and one is
something which i just
closed just now over here now if you
feel that you want to
rename a container let's say like this
is a container which is available
but it's not having a meaningful name
now i want to convert into a meaningful
name like
dev underscore jenkins so that you can
easily do with the help of
docker rename command because that will
rename the
docker container name so that you will
be able to connect
on to that and you can go for the
processing so that's what we can get
over here in this one so this is how you
can do the various management of the
resources
over here so let's go back to the main
content now if
you feel that you want to remove all
these top containers because what
happens that sometimes
we simply stop the container but we do
not remove it from the
docker hose because um we are not
going for the cleanup now clean cleanup
is very required because
these containers are actually taking up
the disk space also
so we need to make sure that we should
be using we should be having like
minimum amount of disk space
utilization so for that what we need
really need to do is that we need to
run docker container prune command so
this will basically help you to
prune or do the cleanup purge of all the
containers which is running on the host
machine here
and that will definitely help us to
remove all the
containers which is in stop status so
that will be simply removed over here in
this one so
uh this really completely removes all
the stock containers onto the docker
host
over here in this scenario now second
one is that it creates
a new image from a container's file
changes now
the way what happens that normally what
we follow is that we use the docker
build command to do the build process
right so docker build command is being
used in that particular way
now if you really want to go for a
preparation
of a new you know image so all you need
to do is that you need to create
a new image from a container file so you
can run the command called docker
container commit command and
you know whatever container is there so
that will be saved or preserved as a
docker image
because sometimes we also do some ad hoc
changes or modifications
on the fly inside the docker container
by going inside the docker container and
doing the
steps so we really need to preserve
those steps and that is the reason why
we are converting a docker container in
the form of a docker image here so
that's what we are trying to perform
here
so docker container is something which
is uh being uh done over here in such a
way
that whatever the steps whatever the
changes we are trying to do so that
needs to be performed over here in this
case
so docker container uh commit command is
being used so that we can get a
particular
you know final image as part of the
container so the container will be
converted
in the form of a docker image over here
and the last one is that how we can
remove an existing container so we can
go for the docker rm command which is
available there using which you will be
able to go ahead and
you can get a particular container
removed from your existing system
so docker arm command is pretty much
there using which we can see that how we
can remove an existing
container from your system as such what
exactly now we are going to see that how
we can perform the various commands
on the containers here
so the very first command which we want
to do here is that uh you know in order
to see that how we can actually remove
all these top containers
but for this one what we really need to
do is that we need to first of all run
some couple of containers
so i'm going to quickly run a container
called docker
run hyphen d httpd
so i'm going to run a particular web
server over here
and it should be able to give me a
proper container up and running
so i can just double check or value that
it as with the help of the
docker ps command so docker ps command
should give me the
proper confirmation that whether the
container is in
up and running over here or not so you
can see that it's up entering from last
11 seconds here now we got a command
where you know for example we have got
some
stopped containers but again you have to
manually remove them one by one
now if you don't want to do that stuff
if you feel that whatever the stock
containers which is available
that should be automatically removed
from your system then we have one
command called
docker container prong now for this what
we really need to do is that we need to
actually stop this container because
again it will be only picked up like
whatever the containers which is
available
in these top setters only those will be
picked up
so i have copied the container name here
in this case
and i need to stop it so that i will be
able to
uh remove it with the prone command over
here in this one
and then i can run like docker container
print command which will basically
remove all the containers
which is in these top status and once
that is done you will be able to see
like that is something which is
completely gone from your system so this
is a way that how it can
not only take care of these top
containers but it's actually being done
so that
you can remove the multiple containers
with the single command itself over here
so this is not something which will be
executed one by one on a different
container
but yes it will definitely take care of
doing the uh changes and performing the
activities
now another thing is that how we can
actually do the uh
commit of a particular docker image
let's say that we got a docker container
which is uh running and there are some
changes like some dynamic changes which
is available there
so you want to save this uh particular
container as a docker image so that
whatever the changes
temporary changes are there so that will
be also saved as
a docker image so all you can do is that
let's say let again
run a particular container
of httpd here so this will help me to
get a particular container from the http
perspective
available of to us so docker ps command
will give me the
option now here i have got a container
in which it's running now if i want to
save this
container let's say that i went inside
it did some modification did some
temporary changes
i want to refer it i want to use it so
how you can do that
so for that what you really need to do
is
you need to run like docker commit
that's a command or you can say docker
because you're going to do a docker
container commit over here so
the command of the container is what we
are going to do so docker container
commit
and then we are going to see like what
is the container so for container we
will be
yes again copying uh that uh particular
container id
and we'll say like custom
image colon version one so we will be
giving a custom name
or a name of a docker image and a tag
over here in this one
so this will basically save my docker
container which is available in this one
in the format of a particular docker
image in a format of a darker
image over here in this case so as you
can see
that almost both of them are having the
same change
but the container which we got uh over
here in this one
so this whatever the changes uh you want
to
wish you want to do you can do that and
you can then put it up into the
uh form of a docker image a final docker
image
and at last if you want to remove it so
docker rm
and container id now this again docker
arm will come
remove only those containers which is in
stop status
so if you want to forcefully remove it
so you will be able to use it
with the help of hyphen f which is the
force will remove which will remove the
container
completely from your system and once
it's removed from your system
you will be able to see like there is no
container
running up and running over here in this
one so docker ps
hyphen a is not something which is up
and running over here in this one
so they completely completely got uh
wiped out from your system
so that's how you basically work on
these commands on this uh particular
uh container related commands here so
let's go back to the main content
right so these are the commands where we
can actually do the management like how
to stop the containers how to remove the
containers
and how to get a new you know docker
image out of the container here
now let's see that how we can list down
all the running containers if you feel
that you want to list down all the
running containers then you can go for
the docker containers ls command
and that will eventually help you to
list down all the containers which is
available there which is uh
being there into your system then docker
stop command is there to stop a
container
so whatever container which is there in
the running sticker so that will be
stored with the help of the docker stop
command and then the restart command is
there using which you can do a restart
of a container
into your system right so once the
container is restart so whatever the
application running inside the container
so that will also be
restarted over here in this one so these
are the different options
which is available using which we can
explore over here in this one
somewhat more commands about the
container so again i am going to run
a container over here of http here
so that i can show you some couple of
more commands over here
now we can run like docker ps or you can
say like docker container less will
which list down on
all the containers which is available to
you which is being uh you know present
in this case
now if you want to do any kind of
operations like let's say if i want to
stop it
now the moment you do these stop over
here so you will be
able to uh stop the container which is
up and running for you
and uh you can come you know whatever
the application is being deployed that
will also not be available to you
because
that's simply uh completely gone for you
now you can see that the docker
container list is not able to show you
that particular option that whether it's
uh being shown or not because it's in
stop status
so in fact you can do a you know start
or you can do a restart so both the
operations
you can pretty much do over here so that
you will be able to have a
complete activity implemented so restart
is also something which is available
which can definitely help you to see
that how the things could really work
and how you can go for the container uh
you know the
management over here in this case so you
can do a container
container ls command to list down what
are the containers which is available
then you can do a restart you can do a
stop also infect start is also there
which can help you to see that how
the containers is are really available
so this is the way that how you can
manage like
you know even the restarts and all
because this really helps you to even do
the restart or bounces
to the application which is present
inside this container so that
also you will be able to see with this
particular component here
so that let's go back to the mean
content
and then um you know killing a running
container so if you really want to kill
a container so for that we can go for
the docker kill
because rocket stop is also going to
stop the container but if you want to
forcefully kill it
so in that case you can go for the
docker kill command to do that
particular
kill on the containers and then if you
really want to go
inside the container and you want to
attach your terminal
so for that you can go for the docker
attach command and with this what will
happen that you can go
inside the container you can do whatever
the changes you want to perform you can
do that
and you can again come back outside that
also so normally typically we use it so
that we can see some errors of
in the logs which is coming up in the
containers and if any kind of issues are
coming up for the applications we should
be able to know that part
now the last one is the uh particular
weight docker weight is there so that
will
block a container and uh it will go in
the wait status so docker weight and the
container id
or the container name you can give so
with that the particular container will
go into the block status
let's see somewhat more uh commands over
here so we can run like
docker container ls again to find out
like what container is available
so you can see that this particular
container is available over here in this
one
now if you see like if i want to get a
attach to this container if i want to
attach my input and output stream with
this container so you can run like
docker attach and the container id
so your terminal will be stuck over here
because it's
taking up whatever the progress which is
going to be done in the container that
will be
in you know a kind of attached to your
terminal over here and you will be
getting the output
but the moment you come out of this like
you say control c
so you will see that you know it's
basically sending the request to the
container that is getting stopped
so you will be able to see like the
docker container list it's not going to
show you because the container is in
stop status so again you have to do the
restart of the container to make sure
that the container is
up and running right so the attach one
will help you to go
uh and attach your standard input and
output
with your container with a running
container but when the moment you comes
out
you will be able to uh disconnect or
shut down the container
and again i had to restart that
container over here in this one
then again of course we have like docker
weight
then container is there so this will
basically put the
container into a block status because
all the requests and all will be
not sent to the container and it will be
blocked
and if you really want to like
uh consume or if you want to make use of
the container you will not be able to do
that
so docker weight command will us kind of
a block the container
and you know if you again uh try to come
out of that so again the request
to the container will be uh resumed and
they will be able to use on that part so
docker read command is being used to
block the container
and then we have docker attached to
attach to the
container the standard input and output
and lastly is the docker kill which is
going to kill the container
and you will be able to see that the
container is
in simply killed status so it's uh you
know it's not like a stopped over here
if it's gracefully stopped
then the exit code definitely will be
zero but in this case
since it's being killed the particular
status is
137 over here in this one so that's a
non-zero status code
so that's how where you will be able to
manage the containers on different
aspects
let's go back to the main container so
these were some of the commands which
was there from the docker
containers perspective let's talk about
some of the commands from the share
command perspective so how we can share
the docker images
so we have a typical pull push mechanism
which is there using which
we can actually interact with the docker
hub or a docker registry
so uh if you really want to pull a
docker image so in that case you can go
for the docker pull command
if you want to push an image to the
registry so you can use for the docker
push command
if you want to execute a command inside
a particular running container
or you want to execute a command or a
script or something like that
so you can go for the docker is a
command and with that the execution will
be done and you will be able to get a
response so that will make sure that yes
whatever the execution you are trying to
do
so that will be done over here in this
mechanism
now let's see that how we can do a pull
and push activity to a darker image
so first of all the pull command is
pretty simple all you need to do is that
you need to say that okay i want to pull
a darker image uh if let's say that our
docker image is already present then
it's
just going to say that it's already up
to date it's already available there
but if uh in some cases you feel that
the docker image is not available and
you want to pull it
so all you can do is that you can give
that a docker image name and
that you can give the tag also but in
this case we are using the tag
as in latest
so that's the reason why even if you
provide or you don't provide it doesn't
really matter
so i'm going to give like a docker pull
a mysql over here
and the moment i hit on this one what
will happen that it says
this a particular docker image is not
available into my system
it's going to download it and once it's
going to be downloaded
you will be able to see that into your
local system
so docker images is something which is
going to help you with the commands and
it will give you the
uh particular ways that how the docker
image is available
so i can run like docker images over
here to see that what are the different
docker images which is available in this
manner now if you really want to move
any of the docker image then of course
you have to do a docker login
and uh you will be doing the
uh you know the connectivity to the
docker hub and then establish the
uh connectivity and all so what you need
to do is that you can run the docker
login command
we will also see this command in the
next particular slide but right now we
are just doing it because
we want to showcase that how the push
really works so
you can actually give your username
that what username you are holding up so
the password does not shows any activity
but yes
still it will let you know that whether
the login is successful or not so in
this case it says login is successful
so all you need to do is that let's say
like i got this custom image and i want
to push it to the docker hub
so you need to rename or you need to do
a tag over here because
the same if you run docker push
custom image colon
version one so if you do that it will
not be pushed into these
uh particular docker hub so it's going
to throw e error
over here that the access is denied so
all you need to do is that you need to
do a tag here
so you have to rename it in such a way
that you should be able to
use uh add your username over there
because
dockerhub will identify that if it's
there with your username
then only it will be pushed otherwise it
will be simply
rejected over there so that's what you
need to do you need to
rename your docker image uh the same
docker image which you have you have to
append your username of the docker hub
and once that is done so all you need to
do is that you need to just run like
docker then push is there
then this image name and then version
one
so the moment you do this what will
happen that it will start transferring
those docker image to the docker hub you
see
this uh specifies that yes this is going
to the docker hub docker dot io
where my username is there and this is
the custom image which is available
there so if i refresh my page on the
docker hub
i will be able to see like this public
repo which is available there
but again this one just requires a
credentials and the login
which we did in just a last command
where we
ran the docker login command to do the
login to the
portal and after that only we are able
to do the setup
and the modifications over here so
that's how you do the login
and you are able to connect on that now
these are some of the
pull and push operations but let's say
that if you got a container which is up
and running like this is
uh right now we are not getting any
container which is available over here
so you can say like docker run hyphen d
hd pd like i'm just running a dummy
container over here so that i will be
able to
show you this command now if you for
some reason want to go inside the
container and want to see some
processing and want to see some content
so you can run the command called docker
azik hyphen id
and there you can give the container id
this is nothing but the
full format of the container id which is
given to you so you can use this one
also
or you can use the shortened also
shortened value also you can use
and then the last we can say like bash
the moment you do this you will be going
you will be going inside the container
you see that this is the host name which
is being shown as the container id
you can do a like psiphon ef command and
it will
throw an error that the ps command is
not available because
you are running this command into the
docker into the docker container
so using these kind of commands which is
not available in container will help you
to identify that yes
you are not on the host machine you are
in fact into the docker container so
that's the reason why you can do it
because for you the parts and all
everything is same the terminal is also
same so
you may not be able to differentiate in
that part so that's the reason why
it's preferred that we use that uh
commands which is going to fail but
that's okay it will give you that okay
this command is failing because i am
into the docker container right now so
that's what we are performing over here
right and you can come out of that but
still the
docker container is going to be still up
and running over here in this case so
the container is not going to
be down over here in this one so that's
how we manage the container we can go
inside and we can check some
informations and get some files there
so these are some of the commands where
we can interact now in order to log into
the docker hub because before doing the
docker push you have to log in
you have to get a credentials and the
connectivity with docker hub
so you can run the docker login command
where you can see that how the execution
can be done
now using the docker login command you
can interact with the
particular docker hub you can set up the
credentials once the
credentials is being set up so what you
can do is that you can go ahead and say
that okay
the configurations is done and we can go
ahead and we can perform the
execution so docker login is a command
where you can give the credentials
docker info is the command using which
you can get the uh information about the
docker tool
so whatever the docker info is available
there so those things you can actually
get it over here in the case
of the docker info so docker info is
going to give you complete information
that what exactly you have the
information available
over here on this one and then we have
the docker history so
using the docker history you can see
history of the docker image that what
exactly
the mechanisms or what are the different
image ids are available there
so this is basically giving you the
complete history on how
the docker image is prepared all the
commands is available there
and that will help you to eventually go
and understand that how the
images can be going on and you can
manage on that part
so these are some of the couple of
options which is available there where
we can see that how the executions
can be done and we can go ahead on that
particular part so
docker history is the command again
which will help you to see that how
you can go for the uh particular
mechanism and you can listen on
on the things over there so docker login
was already done previously when we try
to push the
image but again if you try to run docker
login you will be able to do that
now docker info is something which will
give some additional information about
the docker
and all the informations about the
docker will be given back to you over
here in this one so the
complete clarity then let's say that you
got a docker image called uh
httpd now you want to check the history
of this image that how this image is
prepared what are the different layers
which is available
how many layers are there how much size
is being modified in each and every
layer
so you can see that we got a layer where
we have a particular changes of 7.838 mb
but pretty much the uh from the complete
size of this httpd
the major portion is actually of the
this one the
basic operating system which is being
implemented
and then of course there are some
packages which got deployed due to which
this
uh 60 mb and 7 mp size is coming up
there
so this actually gives you the complete
layer wise mechanism that what are the
informations which is available that how
the modifications actually got modified
and got
changed over here in this one so this is
the additional uh
help which you can get from the docker
to manage the containers here
so these are the ways where you can
interact with the docker
hub if you really want to create a
volumes for the container so you can go
for the docker volume create command
so docker volume create command is there
using which you can create
the docker volumes and you can pretty
much do that
setup so docker volume create is the
command which is available there for
that particular part it will create a
volume for you
now let's see that how we can actually
work with the volume so you can run the
command called docker volume ls to find
out at what are the different volumes
which is available there
now if you really want to create a
volume over here in this one so you can
say like docker volume create
and you can go for the volume name here
now the moment you do that what will
happen that a volume will be created
and you can validate it with the help of
docker volume ls command that whether
the volume is being created
or not over here so this is the way that
how you can manage
the volumes onto the docker host now
let's talk about some of the docker
swamp commands here
now docker swamp commands is there to
set up a particular mechanism where you
can see that how
you can perform a setup you can actually
go ahead and
see that how the setup and modifications
can be done
so docker swam is there where we can see
that how the execution needs to be done
so
you can go for the command called docker
spam init command
this will actually go for an
initialization of our docker swamp
cluster
and once the docker spam cluster is
initialized then you can pretty much go
there and
perform whatever the executions you want
to perform you can do that and you can
execute
as such over there so docker swap in it
is a command using which you can
actually see that how the execution
needs to be done
and how we can perform the uh you know
mechanism and the changes over here so
docker sam init
uh hyphen f1 advice uh adr address is
there which
helps you to see that how the executions
can be done
now joins you have the docker swamp join
command which is available
there now if you go for docker spam join
command so
uh you can have a particular host so
docker's
swam join command is there which you can
run on the node machine
and in that case what will happen that
node will be a part of the
docker spam cluster and then if you want
to leave uh
from the swamp cluster then you can go
for docker swam leave command and it
will be
simply removed from the docker swamp
cluster there some of the couple of
commands which using which we can
initialize or we can
remove from the docker spam cluster here
so docker
spam is already being initialized or
it's been created when the moment you do
the installation of docker so
docker swam in it is the command using
which you can interlash
analyze the docker container now once
you analyze over here
so initial after the initialization you
got a command you
which you want to add it like you want
to run it onto the docker spam
cluster it will act like a worker node
so that you will be able to
deploy the containers on top of that
also if you want to join it as a manager
so you can also get the
join token again so it will give you the
proper command
now if you run like docker node ls so
you will be able to see like what are
the different nodes which is available
there
and for any reason if you're not
comfortable with that and you want to
reinitialize your
docker spam cluster so all you can do is
that you can say like
docker swam a leaf iphone f
and you will be left out of the docker
spam
and now if you want to run like knock
docker node ls you will not be able to
get that
output because it's saying that there is
no uh particular swap manager which is
available
so you can run docker spam in it or you
can run the join command to connect to
that specific node
but we have already left it and nothing
is available over here
so that's a way that how you can manage
like what are the different docker spam
commands
we can typically run to manage the
docker swamp cluster now let's talk
about the docker compose commands now
docker compose commands is actually
there using which we can create
multiple containers it's not only one
container which can we can create we can
create
go for multiple creations of the
containers with the help of docker
compose file so docker compose hyphen
version is the u command which we can
give
you the version of docker compose which
is being used so here we use a
particular vml format file which will
help us to create the multiple
containers we defined the services that
what are the different containers we
want to create here
and then with the help of a docker
hyphen compose dot ml file we can create
or we can have that particular docker
compose file setup over here in this
case
so docker hyphen compose.vml file is
used to do the setup and the
modification so that you will be able to
have the
modifications done and you will be able
to find out a particular
multiple containers gets created all
together so docker compose is there
is the way that how you can do the setup
how you are going to run the docker
compose file so in that case you're
going to run the docker hyphen compose
up command
which will help you to set up like how
the compose can be done
and once you are done with the docker
hyphen compose up command
so using this the compose will be done
and the containers will be
up and running so these are the commands
using which we can manage multiple
containers using the docker compose one
so let's try to run some commands
related to docker compose so docker
hyphen compose iphone version will let
you know that what exactly version of
docker compose is installed into your
system
so you can run typical apt command to do
the installation so docker hyphen
compose the package name
which you can install so that the
executables and the package can be
installed into your
system onto the server now all we need
to do is that we need to create a docker
compose file so what we need to do is
that we need to
create a docker hyphen compose dot yml
file is the default name of the
vml file which we want to create here
that's a standard name so once you
create this all you need to do is like
you need to put some
values attributes the very first one is
the version value that what
version of uh this uh particular
attribute you want to create here let's
say that i want to create a version to
so i will configure here that yes the
version 2 is what i require
i want to set up over here in this one
now again
if i want to configure that what are the
different services we want to run
because
services is the main thing which we will
be running on this machine on the server
here so that's what we require
so then we need to put for a particular
service called web so web service we
want to search
and we want to run and then again we
need to take care about the spacing
because that's a very important part
and we need to provide the values of the
image
and uh all these configurations here so
that you should be able to set up like
how
the uh images and how the docker images
can be built up over here
so uh web is the service which you want
to deploy and then of course the
image is the attribute which is there
for the web that yes engine is the one
which we are trying to build up
now you can give the ports configuration
also so you can say like ports
and inside that you can say like what
port mapping you want to perform so you
can say
like um 8080 so or sorry 80
is what you can dash for the nginx
because it runs on 80 port
but now i have to run like 80 port i
want to attach that port over here in
this one so
i can specify that 80 port should be
available in this one so i'm going to
save this one here and i'm going to run
a command called docker
iphone compose up now this will run the
containers in the
interactive mode but if you feel that i
want to run in the detach mode so you
can say like hyphen d also
which will of course run these ones into
the detach mode and it will be executed
so it will process your docker compose
file and since you have used a standard
name called hyphen
docker hyphen compose dot primal so it
will automatically pick that docker
or details and start creating the
container so that's it for this uh
particular one
in which we talked about that how
exactly we can work on
on all these different docker commands
and how we can make use of
these couple of commas here so that's it
for this one thanks everyone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here